This is a message for all the people.
This is a message from the future,
transmitted to its past. The moment
has come for all people to embrace new
ideas, to solve the most complex problem of all: the long-term survival of complex
life on the planet. This is a call for the
people of Earth to become interplanetary.
It is a plea for reflection.
It is a call to action.
A request for reason. It is time to accept
the need to work towards the creation of
a prosperous Earth, and to bring the light of reason to the far reaches of the galaxy.
This is a message for all people of Earth, and the descendents of earthlings.
It is time to change the world one planet at a time.
Let's face it: there's something crazy
and a bit epic about a project
whose tagline is,
"Changing the world one planet at a time."
The whole idea of InterPlanetary grows out of complexity science.
To be successful in a project like this you need very special people to ask crazy, ambitious questions...
to be radical, maverick, and revolutionary. You know, one of the most important
photographs that we have is the photograph of the Earth from space, because what
that photograph showed us was this one
living planet in an otherwise lifeless universe.
And the fact is,
this planet won't last forever
but we would like the best of what we
have created to last beyond our own planet.
And to do this we need to combine so much of what
humans have created in their histories:
cities, civilizations, great works of art,
great works of music, scientific theories,
incredible artifacts of engineering –
we have to bring them all together.
You have to set yourself an
almost impossible creative task.
What would it take to become an interplanetary civilization?
And everyone knows that when extraterrestrials visit the planet Earth
they crash in New Mexico.
So why is InterPlanetary important now? One is, we're going through a new space race.
There's huge interest on setting up a
colony on the Moon, building a colony on Mars...
There are clearly issues of
sustainable living and living with a purpose,
and it's about the meaning of existence.
We have to find a new language.
We need to find ways of allowing creative minds –
irrespective of privilege and economic
circumstance –to contribute to this project.
We have the technology to do it.
We haven't had the cause –and that's
something that's motivating to everybody.
A festival like this, or a project like this,
can seem like a scientific question–
which it is –but beneath the science,
beneath the engineering, beneath the
technology, is one of the deepest
questions of all – and that is, "What is the ultimate objective of life in the universe?
What we're trying to do now is solve a
really hard cultural problem: we love
worlds that don't really exist.
We in fact like worlds that don't really exist
more than the world that exists.
We now turn to art, to film, or games, to
explore alternative ways of being but
what we want to do is take some of those
worlds that don't exist, and use them to
improve the world that does exist.
And InterPlanetary takes our fascination
in space, science fiction, rocketry, and it
combines it with new ideas and science
with a sense of urgency that we have to
change the way people think about the
complex system. Inject what we find in
science fiction, in literature, infuse it
back into rigorous ideas.
The lives individuals lead now
have consequences over the entire planet,
and so the InterPlanetary perspective
forces everybody to address the global
implications of their local behaviors.
It's time to come together to solve a
huge problem. The problem is the problem of
the long-term sustainability of our planet
and taking the best of what we've
done beyond the confines of our
atmosphere to the rest of the universe.
This is urgent. If we don't do this now,
we're f'ed beyond belief.